in a recent paper scientists showed you
can take human cells and convert them to
stem cells using chemicals
no genes no viruses no rna
just chemicals
so let's take a look at how they did it
what this means and if it really is as
easy as it seems
so what they were doing in this paper
was establishing another mechanism of
cellular reprogramming
this is the process of converting mature
specialized cells into pluripotent stem
cells that have the potential to divide
and to turn into other cell types
this reprogramming process is often
depicted as cells moving back up through
the waddington landscape
but what studies have shown is that you
can define reprogramming into different
stages
in fact here they've divided it into
three phases firstly the initiation
phase
where you want to repress the current
somatic expression of the differentiated
states
secondly the maturation phase where you
start to activate some of these
pluripotency genes and then the
stabilization phase while the complete
pluripotency program is activated and as
hinted at by the name it's stable
it starts it stays as a stem cell
irrespective of how we define these
different phases of potential tasks that
need to be done to get to the
pluripotent stem cell state
the current landmark way of doing
cellular reprogramming is through the
over expression of four proteins the
yamanaka factors oct4 klf4 sucks ii and
semic
which albeit with a relatively low
efficiency is enough information to
provide a cell such that it can turn
into a stem cell
albeit usually with some growth factor
containing media too
but the problem with these approaches is
that you have to deliver the genes that
express these yamanaka factors
in contrast using chemicals to reprogram
cells overcomes this major limitation
that means you don't have to edit or add
any genetic information
no viral factors to deliver genes are
required
you just treat cells and culture which
are already in a solution with a
solution containing these chemicals that
enable reprogramming
reprogramming using small molecules is
inexpensive and easy to control in a
concentration and time-dependent manner
it also offers standardization and is
appropriate for mass-producing cells
but is it really possible
well yes apparently
in fact publications coming out in 2013
and 2016 have shown pluripotent stem
cells can be induced from differentiated
cells using small molecules in mouse
cells
and in fact here is a nice little
timeline of small molecule reprogramming
because i know you're interested it also
showcases where small molecules have
been used for direct conversion from one
human cell type to another skipping the
pluripotent step
cheeky
but direct reprogramming really deserves
its own video
but anyway this timeline is out of date
because induced pluripotent stem cells
have now been made with small molecules
in human cells as demonstrated in this
recent nature paper
so the question you probably want to
know the answer to
well how did they do it
well let's go to the materials and
methods section
and because i read it earlier i
extracted the key information and put it
into this horrific looking spreadsheet
and so this spreadsheet just shows the
different drugs that they added to their
cells at different stages
and the first thing to note is that well
it isn't trivial and i'm only showing
here the additional small molecules that
they used um as there already are
factors that are commonly used in media
when doing even genetic cellular
reprogramming
and then this is even more complicated
when they started with human adult
cells instead of the fetal ones
if you really wanted to know the full
details then obviously the full
ingredient left can be found in the
paper and i've also omitted the
concentrations used mainly because it's
um
meaningless for what i want to say but
what is that first noticeable is that
there are these different stages
not three as i break down earlier but
here they have four different phases
one two three four and at these
different stages they're adding
different small molecules although some
of them are appearing on all of the
stages
and so there are two things you can
consider here
well there's probably a multitude of
things you can consider but we'll stick
for two for now
the first one is what are these small
molecules doing and what does that
inform us about the reprogramming
process
and in conjunction with that performing
single cell rna sequencing and chromatin
accessibility assays to see what types
of things are happening in these cells
during these stages
one of the reasons that understanding
the journey is interesting as well
because we all know it's about the
journey not the destination but in all
seriousness cellular reprogramming is
not that efficient
i mean just take a look at this table
here their efficiencies at best are 2.56
it's pretty
not great really
i want them to be giving me 110
so i think we can all agree it can deal
with some improvements a rational
approach would be to better understand
what needs to happen in each of these
stages so then think okay maybe we
should add this or do this a bit
differently
and then the other informative things is
because not all of the cells
unfortunately survive the journey
some of them make an incorrect journey
or they go the wrong way so why do they
make the journey
and why does it go wrong
and why am i speaking in so many
rhetorical questions
well i don't really know the answer to
that last question so i'm going to go
back to the chemicals what are these
chemicals doing
well a finding that has previously been
made is that to encourage a cell to
reprogram
you need to inhibit tgf-b to signaling
and activate when signaling
these are just two different biochemical
signaling pathways that for interest of
time and because it's been a while since
i really dig deep into it we're going to
bypass for now
but in this very generalized manner this
helps to turn off genes involved in
differentiation and activate genes
involved in cell renewal
features that are seen in stem cells
and so if we go back to that table i
showed you earlier we can see that this
one compound
beautifully named 616452 is an inhibitor
of this tgf beta pathway and so what you
can do is do this reprogramming process
by substituting different small
molecules and seeing how it affects the
efficiency of this reprogramming process
so as i said to further understand the
reprogramming they also performed single
cell rna sequencing which is pretty cool
although it's pretty in line with what
we sort of expect to happen on addition
of these small molecules there is the
initial expression of fibroblast genes
which is the starting cell state
it then goes through this plastic
developmental stage
and then an extra embryonic stage which
that actually was a little bit
surprising to me but for finally
reaching this naive pluripotent stage
so this is the successful reprogramming
trajectory
and then you can use that successful
trajectory to then analyze what happens
when it's unsuccessful
and one of the interesting things from
the study was the fact that the drug
drunken ate
that inhibits junk signaling pathway was
very important for the acquisition of
this intermediate plasticity signature
the interesting thing about this is that
what that rna sequencing data inferred
is that inhibition of this junk
signaling pathway prevented
pro-inflammatory signaling
and so it suggested that this
pro-inflammatory signaling was impairing
the generation of plasticity for further
reprogramming
so in conclusion these results
demonstrated a chemical synergy of small
molecules that manipulate endogenous
cell pathways and epigenetic targets
effectively liberating human somatic
cells from a tightly locked
differentiated state
possibly the most fun sentence i've said
all day
an important aspect of our findings is
that small molecules can unlock the
restricted human epigenetic landscape to
a plastic state through chemical induced
de-differentiation
i'd say that's a close second
so how would this information be applied
it could be developed as small molecule
oral drugs they could be injected
intravenously or it could be applied
topically
in fact one of the components is
retinoic acid which was one of the
chemicals used in work from michael
levin's lab that promoted limb
regeneration and frogs
but would this actually ever work in
vivo
well the next step towards clinical
application would involve confirming
whether there's a possibility of these
drugs inducing tumorogenesis and also
determining the proper concentration
combination and treatment times in fivo
but there is also the possibility of ex
fever treatment and expansion
so that's chemical induced free
programming for you and if you want to
learn more about alternative
rejuvenative approaches then you should
check out this video here
so with that i hope you've learned
something thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening
you